Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis ce qu’on pourrait appeler
un data activist.
Je m’efforce de changer le regard des gens
sur une série d’enjeux sociaux,
et ce, par l’intermédiaire de la collecte,
de l’analyse et surtout,
de la visualisation.
J’insiste sur l’aspect visuel,
parce que c’est
ce qui me caractérise le mieux.
Je suis une personne visuelle,
j’ai besoin d’un support visuel
pour comprendre et assimiler
un nouveau concept.
De la même manière,
lorsque je m’exprime
sur un sujet complexe,
je le fais plus efficacement
avec le support d’un schéma,
d’un graphe, voire d’un dessin.
Alors je visualise le tout.
C’est devenu la manière
la plus naturelle pour moi
de décrire le monde qui m’entoure.
Il y a de ça quelques années,
je me suis rendu compte que -
J’étais en train de cherche
un nouveau boulot,
et je me suis rendu compte
que mon CV traditionnel
était une mine d’informations
extrêmement dense
et difficilement assimilable.
J’ai décidé donc
d’en faire une version visuelle
qui a beaucoup mieux fonctionné
dans la mesure où les informations
de mon parcours professionnel
étaient plus efficacement communiquées.
Et ça avait le deuxième avantage
d’attirer plus d’attention
sur ma candidature,
dû à sa simple forme originale.
C’est pour moi un très bel exemple
de ce que représente
la visualisation de données,
c’est-à-dire un moyen
de rendre intelligible
de larges volumes de données complexes.
C’est aussi de manière visuelle que
je m’exprime sur les réseaux sociaux.
Il y a de ça quelque temps,
je suis tombé sur un tweet de Lara Trump
qui suggérait avec cette carte
que la majorité des États-Unis
votent républicain.
On le voit avec ce rouge un peu partout.
C’est quelque peu paradoxal,
dans la mesure où,
lors des élections auxquelles
elle fait référence,
il y a eu plus d’Américains
qui ont voté démocrate que républicain.
Du coup, je n’ai pas pu m’empêcher
de lui répondre visuellement
avec une carte qui transforme
chacun des comtés en une bulle
dont l’aire est proportionnelle
à son nombre d’électeurs.
C’est selon moi une représentation
beaucoup plus honnête
du vote populaire américain.
Cette carte est devenue virale,
elle a été vue par des centaines
de millions de personnes
au travers de tous les réseaux sociaux,
des grands médias internationaux aussi.
Et c’est pour moi
un excellent exemple que la dataviz,
que la visualisation de données peut avoir
un impact phénoménal sur le grand public.
Ma mission, en tant que data activist,
c’est justement de répliquer
ce genre d’impact.
Mais cette fois-ci pour défendre
des causes sociales
et m’assurer que cet impact
soit positif pour la société.
Il y a un sujet sur lequel j’ai démarré,
que j’ai choisi d’aborder.
C’est un sujet qui m’est personnel,
dans un lieu qui l’est tout autant.
Il s'agit de la situation
migratoire à Bruxelles.
J’ai choisi ce sujet
en réaction à une déclaration
de Donald Trump
qui, il y a de ça quelque temps,
lors de sa visite à Bruxelles,
déclarait que
vivre à Bruxelles, c’est un peu
comme vivre dans un trou à rats.
Et ce, en pointant du doigt
la situation migratoire à Bruxelles.
Je vous avouerais
que cette déclaration m’est
un peu restée en travers de la gorge
dans la mesure où je suis moi-même
un immigré de seconde génération,
issu d’un mariage mixte entre
un père marocain et une mère belge,
eux-mêmes issus d’un mariage mixte
impliquant des religions, des langues
et des cultures différentes.
Et moi, à ma petite échelle, je reproduis
ce schéma multiculturel
au sein de ma propre petite famille.
Vous le voyez,
et vous pourrez le comprendre
sur la base de ce contexte,
que je suis intimement convaincu
de l’apport bénéfique
que peut avoir la diversité
culturelle dans notre société.
Et je pense que si ce sentiment
n’est pas partagé par tous,
c’est en grande partie
à cause de la désinformation
qui circule sur l’aspect
migratoire à Bruxelles.
En tant que data activist,
je me suis donné la mission
de casser ce genre de préjugés,
de faire un reset
des idées préconçues sur le sujet
et d’aller rechercher
des données officielles, statistiques
sur le sujet de l’immigration,
de les analyser et d’en faire
un récit visuel clair et effectif
permettant au grand public
de mieux comprendre la situation,
mais cette fois-ci
sur des bases objectives.
Ce récit s’intitule :
« Bruxelles, un joli melting pot ».
C’est un simple site web,
accessible par tous,
qui commence par vous donner
une idée générale sur l’immigration
à un niveau mondial.
Un migrant sur cinq
vit dans l’une des 20 villes
que vous voyez illustrées ici
par des bulles
dont l’aire est proportionnelle
à son nombre d’habitants.
On y retrouve des villes
comme Londres, New York et Paris.
Et Bruxelles, en fait étonnamment partie.
Je vais vous poser une question,
levez la main si vous voulez
répondre par l’affirmative.
Est-ce que vous pensez que Bruxelles
a une diversité au sein
de sa population plus importante
que celle qu’on pourrait trouver dans les
villes comme New York ou Londres ?
Levez la main si vous pensez que Bruxelles
a une diversité plus importante
que Londres ou New York.
OK. Une large majorité
de la salle a répondu « Oui ».
Effectivement, Bruxelles
est un cas particulier.
Parmi toutes ces villes,
quand on regarde la proportion
du nombre d’habitants d’origine étrangère,
on se rend compte que Bruxelles
est un cas particulier.
En fait, c’est la seule ville occidentale
dont le nombre de personnes d’origine
étrangère est supérieur aux natifs.
Si on s’intéresse de plus près
à la population bruxellois
en tant que telle -
Bruxelles compte 1  200 000 habitants.
Il faut savoir que six habitants
sur dix sont nés non belges.
Deux d’entre eux ont acquis
la nationalité un peu plus tard.
Il nous reste donc 40% de la population,
un peu moins, qui est
de nationalité étrangère.
Je vais vous poser une seconde question :
selon vous, quelles sont les nationalités
les plus représentatives
parmi ces nationalités étrangères
à Bruxelles ?
(Réponses du public)
Il y a pas mal de réponses.
C’est effectivement assez riche
en diversité, on va le voir.
Mais ce qui est intéressant surtout,
c’est de réaliser que la majorité
des personnes de nationalité
étrangère vivant à Bruxelles
sont essentiellement des Européens.
A mesure de 70%.
C’est très loin des discours
et des fausses idées disséminées
par certains partis politiques
ou certains réseaux sociaux.
Si on regarde au niveau
du top ten des nationalités étrangères,
on en a neuf qui sont européennes.
La plus grande diaspora
étant les Français,
suivis des Roumains et des Italiens
en troisième position
qui ont surpassé les Marocains il y a
deux ans, en plein milieu de la pandémie.
Vous le voyez, Bruxelles,
elle jouit d’une diversité
hors du commun :
plus de 180 nationalités au total
officiellement représentées.
Mais pour qu’une société bénéficie
positivement de ce genre de diversité,
il faut s'assurer que la population
étrangère soit proprement intégrée.
Force est de constater
qu’on en est encore loin
et qu’il y a une série de challenges
encore à relever à ce niveau-là.
J’en veux pour preuve
ces quelques graphiques
qui sont des cartes de densité
qui représentent
la répartition de certaines communautés
au sein de Bruxelles.
On y voit en blanc les Belges,
uniformément répartis sur les territoires.
En bleu sont les Européens des Quinze,
concentrés autour
des institutions européennes,
plutôt dans le sud de Bruxelles.
En rose, on y voit les Nord-Africains
le long du Canal,
plutôt dans le nord de Bruxelles.
La représentation que j’ai choisie ici
n’est pas anodine.
Chacun des points que vous voyez
représente une personne unique.
C’est un très bon moyen de représenter
la proportion de population
au sein d’un territoire.
Mais c'est aussi un excellent moyen
d'humaniser les statistiques.
Toi, là, dans le public, tu peux
retrouver ton quartier sur la carte,
et voir un point
qui potentiellement te représente toi.
Ça change complètement la dynamique
de narration de ce genre de récit,
ça le rend beaucoup plus interactif
et plus personnel d’une certaine manière.
Si on revient à l’aspect de l’intégration
et qu’on sélectionne
les trois groupes de nationalités
les plus enclins à vivre en communauté,
les Nord-Africains en rose,
les Turcs en jaune
et les membres
de l’Europe des Quinze en bleu,
on voit que ces communautés vivent
à des endroits complètement
opposés de la ville,
avec assez peu d’interactions au final.
Ça laisse sous-entendre
qu’il y a une forme de ségrégation
qui existe à Bruxelles.
Ce travail a permis de casser
une série de préjugés sur le sujet.
Et tout ça a été possible
grâce à des données brutes,
de source officielle qui ont permis
justement de créer ce travail,
mais qui ne sont pas en soi suffisantes
pour comprendre la situation dans le fond.
Ici, j’ai eu la chance d’accéder
à ces informations,
mais ce n’est pas toujours le cas.
Pour une série d’enjeux sociaux,
les données sont trop sensibles
pour être accédées publiquement
ou n’existent simplement pas.
C'est la raison pour laquelle on voit
de plus en plus d'actions citoyennes
s’organiser justement pour collecter
ces données et pour créer un changement.
Il y a un exemple très parlant
de ce genre de mouvement,
c’est le collectif
Equal Street Name Brussels
qui, il y a de ça quelque temps,
a réuni une soixantaine de volontaires
qui ont, le temps d’une soirée,
répertorier toutes les rues de Bruxelles
portant le nom d’une personne.
Ils ont ensuite fait des recherches
et déterminé
quel est le sexe de cette personne.
Je vais vous poser une dernière question.
Selon vous, quelle est la proportion
des rues genrées de Bruxelles
qui portent le nom d’une femme ?
(Réponses du public)
Ok, on a un grand range qui va de 50 à 2.
La réponse, la voici en image.
Vous l’aurez deviné, en bleu, sont
les rues portant le nom d’un homme,
en rouge, celles portant
le nom d’une femme.
Seulement 7% des rues genrées
de Bruxelles portent le nom d’une femme.
Qu’est-ce que ça vous évoque ?
Est-ce que ça vous révolte ?
Public : Oui.
Effectivement.
Ce qui est d’autant plus troublant, c’est
lorsqu’on réorganise ces rues par genre
et qu’on les réordonne
par ordre de longueur.
On s’aperçoit bien sûr de la rareté
des rues portant le nom d’une femme,
mais à la fois, on s’aperçoit aussi
que la majorité des grands axes,
c’est-à-dire les grands boulevards,
les grandes avenues,
sont réservés aux hommes,
là où on réservera plutôt aux femmes
de petites rues, des chemins discrets,
voire des impasses.
(Rires)
Cette illustration met bien en lumière
l’inégalité des genres dans la
dénomination des rues de Bruxelles
et souligne aussi l’importance
de collecter des données
pour faire changer les choses.
L’indignation que j’ai pu voir
dans certains de vos regards,
c’est la même indignation que j’ai vécue
lorsque Trump s’est permis
de critiquer ma ville natale.
Et en soi, l’essence même
du travail d’un data activist,
c’est justement de créer
un sentiment d’indignation
face aux inégalités
et aux injustices sociales.
La collecte, l’analyse
et la visualisation de données
sont devenues des outils indispensables
qu’il vous faudra utiliser
si vous voulez mener à bien un combat
pour une cause sociale.
Car, comme vous avez pu le voir,
ces outils permettent de traduire
des problématiques sociales complexes
en des histoires claires et engageantes,
capables de toucher à la fois
les esprits et le cœur.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)